a pesar del cansancio en los hospitales
de eeuu el personal médico se prepara
conservo renovada para distribuir las
vacunas que podrían poner fin a la
pandemia de coronavirus con 3000 muertos
al día por el cuvi 19 en el país la
distribución es una carrera contrareloj
varios hospitales tuvieron que comprar
congeladores de almacenamiento ultra
frío para la vacuna de fisión que debe
mantenerse al menos 94 grados fahrenheit
además una vez que la vacuna se saca del
congelador el personal tiene seis horas
para usarla y cualquier contratiempo
podría significar la pérdida de unas muy
preciadas dosis y estamos ajustando
todos los procesos para asegurarnos de
que cuando la vacuna aparezca y llegue
el primer paciente esto se desarrolle de
la mejor forma en firmarse durante los
ensayos los miembros del personal médico
también están tratando de anticipar el
aspecto humano del proceso ante posibles
preguntas sobre la seguridad o efectos
secundarios de la vacuna gripe
estoy emocionada de contribuir al inicio
del fin de la pandemia en mi papel de
hoy como paciente falsa solo estoy
tomando nota de si se entiende bien la
señalización como les ayudo a pensar un
poco mejor el proceso de descongestión
pero incluso si estos ensayos tienen
éxito en un país donde prevalece el
individualismo la vacuna sigue generando
dudas y deja una gran parte de la
población escéptica y queremos
asegurarnos de que realmente sea eficaz
no queremos correr el riesgo de que
empeoren las cosas si realmente se
demuestra que la vacuna funciona
entonces no estará en contra surgió hoy
116 de agua humana aunque la agencia de
medicamentos lópez no me pondré latina
la nación norteamericana espera
inmunizar a 20 millones de personas este
mes y a toda la población para junio